is eric killmonger back in the black
panther sequel or have we gotten our
first shot of shuri as the new warrior
queen based on one shot from the wakanda
forever trailer fans think they've
already gotten it all figured out he has
everything you need to know bury me in
the ocean
with my ancestors that jump from the
ships
because they knew death
was better than bondage
these were the final words eric
killmonger uttered in black panther
after the death of t'challa actor
chadwick boseman though the concept of
death in the advanced city of wakanda is
now seen in an all-new light fans are
eagerly anticipating the sequel to the
massively successful first outing but
the franchise's direction has been an
open question without the lead actor
sumab even hopes that mike will be
jordan's killmonger would be resurrected
redeemed and given the mantle of
wakanda's legendary protector who the
next black panther will be remains a
mystery but thankfully marvel and
director ryan coogler have found their
direction as seen in the first trailer
for black panther wakanda forever the
nation will be going to war with
atlantis and the fearsome leader neymar
the submariner it seems clear that the
next person to done the mask of the
panther won't be fully revealed until
it's much closer to the time for the
movie to hit theaters allowing fan
theories to develop in the months
leading up to it
there are a number of worthy successes
to the mantle t'challa's sister shuri
becomes black panther in the comics so
there are certainly canonical reasons
for her to assume the legacy there's
also nakia who played a pivotal role in
the first film and managed to convince
t'challa to bring wakanda's
contributions to the light however fans
have a different idea entirely as to who
will be the next black panther it all
comes down to one tease at the end of
the trailer that has a number of fans
speculating a wild twist
throughout the trailer fans are treated
to scene after scene of colourful
costumes impressive landscapes and a
stellar soundtrack we get a glimpse of
neymar and the forces of atlantis as
well as the wakanda clearly reeling over
the death of their king and even a
highly anticipated look at the first
appearance of riri williams aka iron
heart what we don't get is a lot of
insight on the mantle of the black
panther or who will be wearing the suit
until the end of the trailer where the
newest protector of wakanda is seen from
behind on a beach ready for battle the
most telling part of the scene perhaps
is not that we see who is in the suit
but the suit itself as one of the small
details noted by fans online is that
this newest look has a gold trim and
stylings of killmonger suit in contrast
to the shades previously worn by
t'challa which were more purple there's
also currently a lot of back and forth
on twitter about whether the person in
the suit has a masculine frame or a
feminine one in response to the scene in
the trailer one fan just said simply
please be michael b jordan others agreed
with another fan proposing the notion
that if killmonger's final wish were
honored perhaps neymar found his body in
the ocean and revived him not everyone
agrees of course with many believing
that the suited figure is shuri
including one who writes
shuri is a new black panther and she
will slay still a fair number of fans
believe or wish it to be the triumphant
return of michael b jordan as eric
killmonger we'll just have to see for
ourselves what's in store when black
panther wakanda forever hits theaters on
november 11th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]